MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
JAN KLEINERT: Hi there, I'm
Jan from the Apps Script
Developer Relations team, and
this is Developer Chat, the
first one that we've
been doing of this.
We have Andrew Stillman
with us today.
I'd like to introduce him a
little bit, and thanks for
joining us.
So, Andrew provides
instructional design,
technology support, project
management, planning services,
execution support, all sorts
of other things for
implementing blended learning
strategies across multiple
schools as part of his job at
New Visions for Public Schools
in New York City.
He works across multiple schools
there, and one of his
primary accomplishments at
New Visions has been the
conception, creation, and growth
of UPD, which is an
ecosystem for teachers to share
creative solutions to
problems that they face and to
build things called hacks,
which I think are basically
the solutions to those
problems so they can share
solutions and promote things
through challenges and
participate and present at
professional meetups
across the city.
So he also works on developing
scripts that can be used for
educators who are Google Apps
for EDU customers as well, and
that's part of his work with
New Visions' Cloud Lab.
So Andrew, thanks
for joining us.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Thanks
for having me.
JAN KLEINERT: We're really
excited to do this.
I also want to mention
my favorite part.
Andrew is also one of the
probably most prolific
developers, publishers in the
Apps Script script gallery.
You've written many of our most
popular scripts that are
in the gallery, things like
autoCrat, Doctopus, which is
my favorite name, and FormMule,
which are really
useful scripts that we're seeing
a lot of uptake with.
So I wanted to start by asking
you how you got involved with
Apps Script.
So what prompted you
to start using it?
ANDREW STILLMAN: Really, I
credit most of this work, in
fact, most of the inspiration
for this work, to one of our
most high achieving principals,
a man by the name
of Mark Dunetz, who is at a
school called the Academy for
Careers in Television
and Film.
But he and his planning team
started the school four years
ago, and they came at the whole
planning process through
the use of Google products
and just found that the
collaboration environment they
were in ended up being one
layer after the next, the best
way to solve a lot of their
planning and systems
problems in school.
And so like layers of an onion,
they just kept building
and sharing spreadsheets and
forms and various systems
around everything from
purchasing to tracking student
behavior issues to keeping a
live copy of their online
grade book and mashing it all
up, integrating it, and
basically creating
their own custom
dashboards and work flows.
And so he was using Apps Script
in a rudimentary way
just to run basic document and
email merges off of triggers,
usually form triggers.
And I came along, and then he
pushed my organization to say,
look, more schools should
be doing this.
We're getting results here.
And his school has gotten
insanely good results.
They just graduated their first
cohort, and they're at a
97% four-year graduation rate,
which is 30-plus points higher
than the city average.
And they're a non-selective
New York City public high
school, which means their
student population is very
much like the rest
of the city's.
And so it's just an
off-the-charts achievement.
And so Mark pushed us to support
the work, which meant
that I had to spend some
late nights learning.
And initially, we had
subcontracted someone to do
some scripting for us.
And I don't have a coding
background, or not a
particularly strong one, and so
initially, I was hesitant,
and I just assumed we needed
to find a professional
developer to do the work.
And gradually, I started hacking
away, and I had a run
in with some folks on the
Docs engineering team.
And they were like, dude,
you can learn this.
Do it.
And so I started writing
scripts, and it blew my mind
how quickly I could be up and
running with things and just
how fast the development cycle
was, particularly with the
code editor.
It was the first time I had a
code editor that was saving
all my revisions, letting me
debug in a very clear cut way,
and so it just transformed
my own learning process.
And so suddenly, I was producing
like the first
really robust document merge
utility for Google Docs, and I
had fan mail.
And it was just an unexpected
journey that just came about
through a demanding and
successful principal who
pushed me to figure out how to
make these things better.
So a lot of my challenge
has been, ultimately--
like New Visions supports
76 New York
City public high schools.
So if we're going to take the
esoteric script-based
workflows that exist in one
school and move them into
other schools, we have to think
about how to make them
as user friendly as possible.
And so my first step was to
really learn UI App and figure
out how to put everything
a menu.
So if something needed to be
configured or a document
needed to be connected to the
script or whatever, there was
no hard-coded dependencies.
And so I quickly got into trying
to engineer Apps Script
solutions that would be
accessible to nontechnical
users, and that was the
motivation for the design of
most of the scripts
I've developed.
JAN KLEINERT: And that's one of
the things that strikes me
when I try your scripts.
I find that they are easy
to set up and use.
You don't expect your users to
be going into the code editor
and changing values and setting
it up that way.
You have these nice,
menu-driven, almost like a
Wizard-driven setup flows,
which, I think, make life a
lot easier for your users.
Even though it's probably more
work for you as the developer
to put that system into place,
I think it's pretty helpful.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Yeah, I mean,
I'm just not going to get
adoption, at least not by the
people that I want adopting
the scripts, unless
I put it in a
drop-down menu or a widget.
So, yeah, and initially, I was
using ScriptProperties mostly.
We started using ScriptDb a bit
more for storing, but just
figuring out how to
store values and
have persistent memory.
We're also now using
UserProperties a fair amount,
because we're interested in
actually having analytics on
usage by school.
So those have been really
important things to learn.
JAN KLEINERT: Cool.
So can you tell us a little
bit about some of these
scripts that you've created?
ANDREW STILLMAN: Sure, yeah,
and maybe a screenshare at
this point would make sense.
I want to show some of these
what I would call modular
building blocks.
We've tried to think about--
I love LEGOs.
I feel like most good softwarers
like LEGOs.
So just the idea that we have
these flexible core building
blocks, two of which are
merge utilities.
So anytime you see this mule
icon, which I'll cut away to a
version-- oh, wrong one.
that's the autoCrat.
So this mule, which kicks and
neighs and what not, is just
an animated GIF.
But this is the formMule, and
this script is responsible for
taking form data on a trigger,
or spreadsheet data, and
generating merged emails.
And there's a bunch of email
merge utilities already in the
script gallery.
But this one, in particular, has
the UI to configure it in
lots of different ways.
And currently it can send up
to three templated emails.
The templates are totally
configurable.
They can be sent
on conditions.
And so ultimately,
this becomes a
really important staple.
The other thing this does is
it will create a merge
calendar event on a calendar
ID of your choosing.
So if you want to have a
combination of an email sent
and an event created, it
can let you do that.
The last thing this script does
that ends up being really
important is that it lets you
select columns in which, when
the form data comes in, a
formula can be copied down
from row to row automatically.
And what's powerful about that
is that it means that your
forms can have a validated
drop-downs of items that then
get looked up in
another sheet.
And that little stitch ends up
making any Google Form into
something that behaves much more
like the front end of a
relational database, so things
like student name, teacher
name, class period, anything
that is a validated piece of
information that might have
things looked up on.
So, student email, teacher
email, start time with period,
end time with period, those
kinds of things can be
referenced in secondary sheets
that are running in the same
spreadsheet as the form.
And so what formMule does is
it allows you to copy those
values down from row to row
every time a form trigger
runs, and it means then that
your merged emails suddenly
take on a whole new power.
Because you can email particular
people based on
incident type, or you can only
trigger a calendar event when
a particular drop-down is
chosen in the form.
It just radically changes
the power of what a
Google Form can do.
So that's one of the scripts.
The other big merge script is
a document merge utility
called autoCrat.
And the reason it's called the
autoCrat is so you don't have
to be the bureaucrat.
But that is Stalin's mustache
that's twitching
around on the autoCrat.
And those little tags that you
see on his chest are the
notation that we use
for the merge tags
in a document template.
So this is a Google document
merge utility.
It basically produces either
a PDF or a Google Doc.
It merges in rows of data.
It merges into the header,
the footer, the body.
It preserves formatting.
It's fairly robust, and the
field mapping is all
accomplished through a UI.
So when I'm storing field
mappings in a JSON string, and
then those settings are
persistent, and it just works.
It also brings in sharing, so
you can, in the process of
merging a document, also merge
in Collaborators and also
organize the document in a
folder of your choosing.
So it means the schools can
now do things like have a
mastered lesson plan generator
where lesson plans are
deposited in a lesson library
for the school, pre-shared
with the teacher, and
yadda, yadda, yadda.
So this is the second
big building block.
I'm just going to cut away
to this workflow.
This is an example system.
This is one of the more
sophisticated systems that
schools I work with
are playing with.
And again, these are designed
as part of an initiative
called the Cloud Lab, which was
something we just launched
this summer.
But it's essentially engaging
schools as design partners in
systems rethinking.
And I think for the first time
in the history of software, we
actually have enough flexibility
and usability in
the basic systems building
blocks that school level
people can actually
make these things.
JAN KLEINERT: Well, that's
interesting.
So the people that are working
with these building blocks
that you've put together
are not programmers.
They're teachers who just have
an interest in making their
lives a little less
complicated.
ANDREW STILLMAN: They're
power users at the
school level, right?
So they're going to the script
gallery saying, I've got a
Google Form that I want to
have generate a document.
The secretaries need to have a
way to generate a lateness
letter, blah, blah, blah.
There's a million and one
different systems in schools
that there are no essentially
provided systems for.
And a lot of the essentially
provided systems, especially
in New York, are antiquated.
So many schools operate with
tremendous inefficiencies.
And as soon as they start to see
what these building blocks
can do, it opens up 50,000
different things that they
suddenly are like, why are we
using a triplicate form with
carbon copy?
Ugh.
They just start cobbling
these things together.
So this is a workflow that shows
the logic for what's
called a conduct intervention
communication log, which is a
catcall form for logging
everything from school home
attendance outreach calls, to
behavior incidents, to parent
teacher conferences,
to whatever.
So it's like an anecdotal
capture point.
And then it has all these
emails triggers.
So we have all these
conditionals built that have
to do with, do you want to
notify the kid's adviser?
An adviser is usually, in most
small New York City schools,
the point person
for most social
emotional issues for kids.
So keeping that person in the
loop is really important.
This radically changes the
way you can do that.
JAN KLEINERT: So I have a
question for you about this.
So prior to having a
script-based solution like
this, the script in Docs and all
of this workflow, how was
this process being managed?
Or was it being managed?
ANDREW STILLMAN: Prior
to scripts?
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah, what
was happening before?
ANDREW STILLMAN:
It was a mess.
Oftentimes, it just
wasn't happening.
If I have a behavior incident
with a child in one of my
classes and I want the adviser
to know about it, it would
mean often physically finding
that person in the midst of a
busy school day or sending them
an individual email which
then gets lost in an inbox
somewhere and that doesn't
have a clear counting
attached to it.
So there was no centralized way
for anyone to look at a
single student and understand a
history of interactions and
a history of home contacts
that might have happened.
It'd be like calling your credit
card company and having
them not know anything about
you, whereas in most other
industries, you have a
persistence and a coherence of
just information management.
And this kind of stuff just
doesn't exist in public
schools for the most part.
So this really changes the
underlying fabric of how a lot
of these schools are
able to work.
JAN KLEINERT: Great.
Cool.
So this one seems to use not
just autoCrat and formMule,
but another one as well.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Yes,
the pushData.
JAN KLEINERT: My
favorite icon.
ANDREW STILLMAN: So we
need to show off
that icon for a second.
So pushData uses a hamster
because one of my favorite
things about Apps Script is it
works almost at the speed of a
human being.
It literally looks like
a screen macro running
when you see it.
And so this script, in
particular, it does
essentially the job
of ImportRange.
ImportRange is a function
that's unique to Google
Spreadsheets that lets you bring
a specified range of
data into another spreadsheet
just using
its spreadsheet key.
But it's limited in terms of the
number of rows of data it
can handle, and it can really
slow down your spreadsheets if
you're working with
larger than 2,000
rows of data or something.
So pushData is a replacement
for that that
pushes on a time trigger.
And it lets you choose a source
and a destination
sheet, and it becomes a console
for mapping all the
relationships between
spreadsheets in a root folder.
So if you have a folder for a
system that has, let's say, 10
or 15 different spreadsheets
involved, I could maintain,
for example, a master student
list in one location, and then
I could have certain columns of
that pushed out to as many
other locations as I want on
a regular time trigger.
So it then allows you to do
things like VLOOKUPs on
student name in 50
different forms.
You could have as many different
systems as you want
that are all keyed on the same
up-to-date, synchronized
master list.
So it in some ways is a
substitute for having a true
relational database.
School-level people are not
going to be able to set up a
relational database.
They need a flexible spreadsheet
environment.
JAN KLEINERT: Something where
they don't have to worry about
hosting and all of that.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Exactly.
Right, so this is an
underlying piece of
infrastructure for that.
So in this system here, pushData
is syncing the master
student list and the master
teacher list with these two
other spreadsheets, one of which
is the back end to the
actual form, and then the other
which is an attendance
tracker, which basically is in
this case allowing the school
to easily see on a one-to-one
basis whether a phone call
home was made by the advisers
for any given the absence.
So it lets you really maintain
a lot of transparency around
what kind of outreach is
happening around attendance.
So anyway, really,
what is that?
Three scripts that
do all this.
JAN KLEINERT: That's
fantastic.
So do you find that there have
been any particular challenges
in getting teachers or
schools to adopt
these types of workflows?
Or do you find that once they
see one working, they kind of
get the value right away?
What are some of the challenges,
I guess?
ANDREW STILLMAN: Yeah, some of
the challenges have been--
I mean, initially when we were
using these scripts--
make a copy of a Google
spreadsheet that
has a script in it.
And the script comes with it.
And that's great.
But these scripts are
all dependent on
ScriptProperties being set.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
ANDREW STILLMAN: And the
configuration of these scripts
is not obvious to--
I mean, even though it's run
through a UI, you have to
figure out what it's
even asking you.
Like what is a field mapping?
Your average school employee,
there's a learning curve.
JAN KLEINERT: Sure.
ANDREW STILLMAN: One of the
things we had to overcome was
the fact that ScriptProperties
don't copy with scripts.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
ANDREW STILLMAN: And so, I
developed a way to get the
ScriptProperties to output as
a code string, essentially,
that could then be pasted back
into a function that would run
on install.
JAN KLEINERT: Oh, interesting.
OK.
ANDREW STILLMAN: These are
self-configuring scripts.
So once someone takes the three
or four hours to build
one of these systems, it can
then be packaged in such a way
that the next person who comes
along and has to set up that
system has a copy doesn't have
to do any of the configuration
steps in the scripts.
The scripts are preconfigured.
So that was a really important
implementation shift that we
had to make.
The other has been in preserving
relationships
between spreadsheets.
Like many of these systems
require multiple spreadsheets.
So you've got to have pushData
sending things across
spreadsheets.
And any dependency on
document ID was
creating a huge problem.
Because you could go to set up
the new system, and everything
would be pointing to
the old system.
JAN KLEINERT: Right, I see
what you're saying.
ANDREW STILLMAN: In creating
pushData, what I did was I
made it refresh all of
the document IDs on
install using file name.
So I was referencing the root
folder that it was sitting in,
quickly going through all the
files and pulling in their
document IDs so that every
single mapping that exists in
pushData is valid
in the new copy.
Those kinds of things ended
up being really important.
And then lastly, just making
the distribution of these
things really super easy.
Like if you ask someone to
download six different
spreadsheets and put them
in a folder, you've
already lost them.
So we built, recently something
called the Cloud
Labs Systems Replicator.
It's kind of an intimidating
name.
JAN KLEINERT: I like it.
ANDREW STILLMAN: I should
probably change it.
But essentially, this is a
private login-only web app,
which I recently learned
how to make.
And it's essentially accessing
a subset of
folders in my Docs list.
And these are folders that each
contain a fully packaged
system, including
documentation.
So I can go, for example, into
After School Credit Recovery
and Attendance System, which
is the system we were just
looking at.
Oh, no, this was a
different system.
And you can see underneath the
documentation is previewed, so
you can make a decision
about whether this
system is for you.
We try to include systems
diagrams, because we find
these are really helpful for
less technical users to
understand, and installation
instructions, so making all
this stuff abundantly clear.
And then the other thing we
did is this is a single
function that copies
an entire folder's
contents to your drive.
So there's no folder
copy native to
Docs, as far as I know.
So when I click this,
it literally will
generate the folder.
And you can see--
I'll blow this up for the
sake of our users.
You'll see the system being
replicated right into the
person's drive.
JAN KLEINERT: Oh nice, OK.
ANDREW STILLMAN: So this is
another way that we have kind
of lowered the barrier for
adoption for schools.
JAN KLEINERT: Reducing the
chances of user error,
forgetting to copy one of the
important pieces of the
puzzle, and things like that.
ANDREW STILLMAN: It also means
that any school is now
potentially a publisher
of a system.
It completely shifts
the innovation.
We'll call it an ecosystem.
You no longer are dependent,
necessarily, on a software
developer to do the systems
thinking side of it.
You have LEGO building blocks,
and then you have people on
the ground working with the
kids who understand the
problems deeply and who can then
design the system the way
it needs to be.
JAN KLEINERT: And
then share it.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Right.
And there's no delay.
There's no six months of waiting
for the issue queue to
be updated or for the big
student information company to
decide that this
is a priority.
The school has it tomorrow.
JAN KLEINERT: That's exciting.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Yeah,
it's a lot of fun.
JAN KLEINERT: Awesome.
So we have a few minutes left,
and I have one more
question for you.
But first I just want to see
if there's anything on our
Moderator page.
Let's see.
This morning, we didn't have
anything specifically about
this session.
It looks like we still don't.
There is a support-related
question there that we'll
answer separately.
So my last question for you was
what would you like to see
from Apps Script
in the future?
What are some things-- oh, I
see your eyes twinkling--
that would make your life easier
in developing these
types of solutions?
And specifically since you
specifically seem to work
mostly with educators, what in
that area would make your
development life easier?
ANDREW STILLMAN: Honestly, at
this point, there is much more
for me still to learn about
Apps Script than
I've had time to learn.
I mean, I'm not just
a developer.
So I spent a lot of my
time in schools, and
I still want to learn scriptDb
inside and out.
I've had the pleasure of working
with some Google
Summer of Code interns
this summer.
My understanding is that there's
still some reliability
issues with scriptDb, not major,
but in particular, when
dealing with large
batches of data.
And I think there's already an
issue in the tracker on this,
but it sort of severely hampers
the way it works when
you can't write large
numbers of rows.
A lot of what I want to be able
to do is allow the user
to maintain their data set in
a spreadsheet, but have a
secondary warehouse where that
data is stored for longevity.
JAN KLEINERT: Interesting.
OK.
ANDREW STILLMAN: There are
limits to the number of rows
in a spreadsheet.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
ANDREW STILLMAN: In particular,
when you start
adding formulas, and the
performance of spreadsheets
degrades so that they become
almost unusable beyond like, I
don't know, 6,000 or 7,000 rows
if you have things like
VLOOKUP running.
JAN KLEINERT: Very
complicated.
ANDREW STILLMAN: It's just
impossible, yeah.
So I would really like to make
sure that scriptDb can do
things like that.
And I almost feel like there
needs to be a clearer library
where you can just literally
just send a spreadsheet range
into ScriptDb, and
pull it back--
JAN KLEINERT: I like
that idea.
That's a nice one.
ANDREW STILLMAN: --without
having to think too much.
And I'm sure there's already a
library written to do that,
and I just don't
know about it.
But I guess the other thing I
would love to see is just a
ready-made HTML editor
UI element.
Because a lot of what I'm having
folks do is develop
things like an email merge
template, or a document merge
template, or whatever.
And particularly in the email
side of things, it would be
really cool if people
could author HTML.
And I know this is now
possible through--
I think it's through
HTML service.
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah, it should
technically be possible, yes.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Right.
So I would love to see proof
of concept on that.
JAN KLEINERT: So like a rich
text editor that you could--
ANDREW STILLMAN: Rich
text editor that--
JAN KLEINERT: Widget that you
could just stick in there.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Yeah. because
right now, I have folks
editing email templates
in a spreadsheet cell.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Which is really
tricky for folks who,
even figuring out how to get a
hard return in a spreadsheet
cell is not self-evident.
Because I want to allow HTML,
I'm having to have them create
break tags.
And I don't want my end users
to have to code in HTML to
produce their templates.
So that's a big one.
And then I think lastly
we depend so
much on Google Forms.
JAN KLEINERT: Yes.
ANDREW STILLMAN: And often, the
response I get when I say
Google Forms needs to have
things like range-dependent
drop-downs.
Like hugely important for us,
because we're dealing with
ever-changing student
registers.
We want to be able to validate
form data when it comes in.
And so we can't just have
open text fields.
And to be able to preserve a
3,000-student list in such a
way that it's always exactly
a match with our student
register in a school requires
all kinds of ludicrous
workarounds.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Right.
I can imagine.
So more powerful forms and
then better integration.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Yeah, I think
the Forms product itself, but
then yeah, to be able to modify
Google Forms through an
API would be phenomenal.
I mean, that and additional form
widgets, like date, be
able to validate something
like an email.
So yeah, I mean, forms
are huge for us.
JAN KLEINERT: Right.
Every time I've talked to
somebody who's even remotely
in the education world, they
always mention Forms.
And wishing Forms could
do x, y, or z.
So we definitely hear the--
JAN KLEINERT: Yeah, I mean, I
was showing someone a Google
Form the other day.
And they were like,
oh, so this could
replace Microsoft Access?
And I was like, yes, it can.
But there's a number of
workarounds you have to
develop still.
And so getting rid of those
would be awesome.
JAN KLEINERT: OK.
Well, we'll definitely
pass that feedback
along to the team.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us today.
And I just really appreciate
you spending your time here
with us, and also everything
that you do for the Apps
Script community, and for all
these teachers out there.
ANDREW STILLMAN: Thanks so much
for having me. it's been
a pleasure.
JAN KLEINERT: Thank you.
All right.
ANDREW STILLMAN: All right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]